I think you have to negotiate with your
husband first of all you have to
negotiate when you're going to have a
date why did you assume this was about
sexual submission I didn't I thought we
were going to
dance mom wins that round yeah you for
you good one
t everybody is going to have something
wrong with them in relationship to the
pursuit of what's best like I'm not
smart enough I'm not attractive enough
I'm not charismatic enough I don't have
enough money I don't have enough
influence like there's going to be a and
God's response is I don't care what your
impediments are you can overcome them
how do you overcome bitterness and
contempt in a
relationship you'd have to figure out
every single problem right you'd have to
go down to the bottom with every single
problem if we have an interpersonal
issue let's say it's come up a couple of
times so that I I can be sure it's there
neither of us are going to want to
Broach it particularly and the reason
for that is that as you delve into
something like that you go into The
Inferno often when the hero see sees the
monster the first time he'll turn tail
and run and usually what'll happen is
people will cry insult each other or
they'll further the fight or they'll run
out of words and they just stop before
they actually solve the problem and then
you might ask why are people afraid to
delve into
it I was out with my friend John pepper
who was an ordinary guy who ended up
inace boyfriend John was very funny very
tough kid like very very wty four or
something charismatic kid and uh we were
on some gravel and I had my hand down on
the gravel for some reason and he
stopped the 10 speed on my hand and he
did it by accident but it tore it up
pretty badly so all three of my fingers
were like torn to rat and when we
started to fight Andrew Cox the first
thing he did was grab my hand twist the
hell out of it and um anyways that ended
badly and I got harassed by about being
beat up by this little rat of a kid for
like a year so which was definitely not
the least bit of fun no so now you know
yeah well you know what goes around
comes around hey well welcome back to my
podcast thank you for being here good to
see you good to see you too good to see
you in your house and everything yeah
wow a house nice podcast Studio thanks I
spent a lot of time choosing wallpaper
like a lot of my life is gone from
choosing wallpaper I've seen a lot of
wallpaper well I think it was worth it
it's good to have your priorities right
thanks Jordan actually chose this one
yeah I like it yeah well thank you even
though Jordan
[Music]
chose uh so I took a bunch of questions
from my audience said you guys were
coming on and so I think we're just
going to roll through as many questions
as we can get through which should be
like three we'll see we'll see K you
ready we're going to start with an easy
one
uh Bob Dylan or Tom
weights well Jordan would say Tom
weights you better say Tom
weight I'd say Tom that's a hard one but
we do listen to a lot of Tom weights and
not so much Bob
Dylan so that's you're stay in middle of
the road but but Tom weights I'm going
with Tom weights Bob Dylan Tom weights
has way more good songs like almost
every Tom white song is good and there's
like there's a lot of them and he's
profound and yeah he's great and Tammy
pointed him out to me just to make that
clear yes yeah when I was a young woman
I used to go to record stores and choose
records by their covers and I chose a
Tom weight's album and uh took it home
and put it on and thought wow what this
you would choose albums by their cover
yeah well that there was a lot of that
in the70s really yeah well how else were
you going to know ni how were you going
to know you took we bought a lot of
random albums everybody's album
collection had like a large proportion
of Duds in it plus the other things a
record companies used to do too which
was hyper annoying was they' put one
good song on a collection of like 30
Clunkers so we we had to make mixtapes
too which took a lot of work right
because we were recording on cassette
tapes so making a mixtape was a many
hour job and part of your reputation as
a teenager was definitely dependent on
the quality of your mix tape we we made
mixed CDs people don't do that at all
anymore everything's just Spotify
playlist playlist they make playlist
that's easy though even burning a CD was
kind of a pain and you had to download
off like lime wire or something yeah
well we had to do it with records so you
had to borrow your friends records to
playlists
MH so like a good mixtape that was a
valuable item you give that to who you
have a crush on you had to pick your you
had to pick your cassette Pro properly
too and part of your reputation as a
teenage boy was whether or not you knew
the difference between the different
grades of cassette tapes they made good
Christmas presents they did they did
mixtapes well we we gave CDs out as
Christmas presents for a while mixtapes
Western blues oh yeah that's right yeah
because we collected a lot of old
western music in Boston because in
Boston when you were a kid you could go
down to the vinyl shops and you know buy
records for 50 cents they weren't worth
anything and so I collected a lot of old
western music and sometimes that was
from the covers too because the cheesier
the cover the better the song was
basically the rule for Western vinyl hey
guys if you didn't know my dad's going
on tour for his upcoming we who wrestle
with God book if you guys like the
biblical series on YouTube You're Going
to Love This tickets are available at
jordanbpeterson.com and honestly if
there are any of the lectures you guys
should go to it's one on this tour it
could change your life listening to
Dad's lectures brought Mom closer to God
and I think that's what he's hoping to
do for people I'm not sure what other
lecture you can go to that's trying to
deliver that Mom's going to be opening
for him and hopefully I can come along
to some of the shows but we'll see how
baby George and my sleep feels about
that tickets are available at
jordanbpeterson.com for shows in the US
starting in February there are also meet
and greet tickets still available I hope
you enjoy this episode okay going in a
completely different
direction uh how to adapt to submitting
to your partner when you're a stubborn
strong-minded
woman I guess that's for
me says the stubborn strong minded
woman okay what do you think well I
think you have to negotiate with your
husband first of all you have to
negotiate when you're going to have a
date and then you have to honor that and
the way you honor that is when the day
comes that that's the day of the date
you have to make sure you're arrested
and it's up to you it's not up to
anybody else to take that time time it's
up to you and why did you assume this
was about sexual
submission uh I didn't I thought we were
going to
dance mom wins that round yeah you do
good for you good one Tammy yeah
yeah yeah well that's the idea of
submission like part of this strong
woman thing here that this questioner is
Tangled Up In is there's no submission
in a relationship if you have any sense
nobody submits that's ridiculous well in
the in the Bible I think she's referring
to the in the Bible when it says submit
to yeah but submit in the Biblical
context is a very complicated notion and
it's not just women to men it's men to
women too well it it's also predicated
on the idea in the biblical Corpus that
if you're married properly your husband
has already submitted himself to while
in the Jewish tradition to the Mosaic
Commandments to the prophets and the law
and in the Christian tradition that he
submitted himself yourself to the
ultimate authority of Christ and so it
isn't that you're submitting to your
husband it's that you are placing
yourself in a hierarchy that's aimed at
the highest possible a yeah so between
the two of you you're submitting to the
marriage yeah and what's best for the
marriage and the marriage is a Sacrament
and that means that it's a marriage
under the under the opes of Christ and
God and what that means is that you're
both aiming up you're both acting in
each other's B interests and your own
best interest but in the highest sense
and that your communication
is based on logos which is the Divine
word which is truth and so if all that
is happening there's no submission ex
except in in a really narrow sense so
you're submitting to to what's best yeah
you're sacrificing what's lowest to
what's highest and that's a submission
of sorts but really what it is is a it's
a disciplining of your whims because
when you say you want something that
isn't really accurate generally what you
mean if it's a selfish desire is that
some whim in you some short-term whim
that's only operating for immediate
hedonic gratification has got you in its
grip and you think well this is what I
want it's like yeah that's one way of
looking at it but a more accurate way of
looking at it is that something in you
wants it and you've submitted to
that and so you're not supposed to do
that and so partly what you do in
marriage if you have any sense is that
you help each other organize your wants
and needs in a proper hierarchy that's
oriented up and then you might ask well
what does it mean up you know because
that would be the moral relativism
standpoint well you know up is a matter
of dispute or a matter of contention
which is also complete bloody rubbish
because
up is partly an emergent property of
what will sustain your relationship over
time so if you're interacting with the
same person multiple times and you
submit them to your whims or you use
power that whole relationship is going
to go south in no time flat they're
going to get bitter and resentful and
work against you and and even if they do
submit they're going to do it
begrudgingly and so that's certainly
going to do your life in in about 5
seconds flat and so you're submitting to
a pattern of attention and action that
enables you to engage in optimized
reciprocal interactions across a very
long span of time there's nothing
arbitrary about that it's the same thing
that kids do when they make a
friendship so what kids will do when
they come together is they one kid will
offer the other a game and the first
rule is you offer the game and the
second rule is the other person has to
want to play that's for negotiation yeah
yeah that's the beginning of the
negotiation to agree on the game and to
g to agree on the aim well then you have
to see if it's fun to play with that
person which means all the micro games
within the game are also voluntary and
aimed in the proper direction which
would be at least keeping the fund going
and then at a higher level keeping the
relationship going and so then when a
child Chang games together with a person
that's the beginning of friendship so a
friendship is a game of
games right and then there's an ethos
that's associated with the friendship
that would have to do with trust and
respect that without which those
repeated interactions are no longer
desirable and so that's all what
constitutes up and if you have any sense
you submit to that because yeah why
wouldn't you if you especially once you
understand it and I think there's a lot
of talk in the red pilled sphere that's
very popular online that's if you're a
man and you're in a relationship with a
woman they should listen to you because
you're the man and it's basically as
simple as that I see and what you're
saying is in the Bible it's it's submit
to a higher good yeah well the man is
supposed to reflect Christ but so is the
marriage and I don't know if the
redpilled guys are doing that well
they're not doing that if they if any of
the submission is based on power because
one of the things that's made
staggeringly crystal clear in the
biblical Corpus
Moses is punished dreadfully for using
power even though he's a great leader
right he is he is condemned to death
before he enters the promised land
because he uses power when God tells him
to use his voice yeah right and then the
Pharisees and the scribes and the
lawyers who are Christ's Paramount
enemies are and that also goes for the
Romans as well they at least in part
people who use power force and compul
compulsion instead
of negotiation voluntary negotiation
towards a higher good so the notion that
the judeo-christian tradition for
example is patriarchal in that it
justifies the use of masculine Force
that's that's utterly preposterous
there's nothing about that's that that's
even vaguely true and you see that in
part two because well first of all right
when the biblical Corpus opens one of
the first pronouncements is that both
men and women are made in the image of
God right there's an absolute insistence
in that and then you know the feminist
critics will say well yeah but Eve is
cast in a bad light it's like yeah so is
Adam Eve Eve takes the first bite but
Adam submits to her Temptation in a
second and then he blames her for his
faults which men do to women all the
time you know and vice versa I mean
we're pretty good at that both ways but
and then in the Christian tradition I
mean Christ treats women as of equal
value in a radical manner throughout the
entire Corpus of his ministry which is
really when we have any documentation of
his actions and he he takes a lot of
flock for
that so no there's no
submitting cool plus it's impossible
anyways you try to get a woman to submit
like good luck it's just not possible
not for very long they're
[Laughter]
slippery
who got Jordan Uggs I posted a picture a
picture of us for Christmas I was like
this is such a nice family photo and you
were wearing your green silk pajamas and
that's all anybody talked about it's
like and I didn't it didn't even occur
to me when I was posting it my Hugh
Hefner fantasy yeah that that got
mentioned a lot I'm sure the I thought
that yeah yeah yeah yeah I thought that
was funny I was looking through robes
and I thought yeah well you know oh this
is on purpose green satin that's that's
just perfect yeah well you got to have a
sense of humor you
know he wears them all the time it's not
just
funny yeah but you like them yeah
they're all right yeah see yeah I knew
they're soft you know they're nice
they're shiny shiny just like yeah I
know it's easy to attract a crow yeah
okay a bunch of people asked about this
uh in different forms but it's about how
to have emotional control so a lot of
people having trouble controlling
emotions so suggestions on how to keep
emotions under control
pause you know you don't you don't keep
them under control necessarily what you
do is you notice that you have something
that is in Discord so you have an
emotion about it right so you're
responding you're reacting to something
emotionally you pause and you and you
don't say anything because now you're in
a place of the unknown right you're in
the place of the unknown and so you have
to wait until you can see what the next
right thing is to do and
um and you can be really out of control
upset and the best thing you can do for
yourself right then is to breathe and
wait and just try to keep it steady and
figure out listen and listen so it's
negative emotion that people are talking
about rather than emotion per se because
nobody's that worried about a sudden
Outburst of Good Humor or Joy so right
right so you know although that can get
you in trouble but Carl Jung said
emotion emerges where adaptation is
weakest and that's associated with the
idea of chaos and so if we're talking
and you say something that disrupts the
flow of conversation and causes an
outbreak of emotion that reveals some
impediment or obstacle to our further
communication maybe with regard to the
topic that we're discussing or with
regard to our broader relationship and
the emotion is actually it's an
indicator of
some element of the territory we both
inhabit that hasn't been mapped properly
and so the emotion comes up as a warning
and it says unknown thing happening
unknown and threatening thing happening
and then it it doesn't it doesn't it's
not necessarily much more specific than
that and then it can take a lot of work
to figure out exactly what the problem
is right and and but that's what you
want to do is you want to and you don't
want to jump to the conclusion for
example that you're right and the other
person is wrong which would be highly
convenient and easy for you and and you
can understand why people would want to
do that because it's the least amount of
effort but the reason you shouldn't do
that is because it's possible that
you're the idiot and then you might even
ask well even if I am the idiot if I can
convince the other person that they're
stupid and wrong why shouldn't I do that
and the answer is well you might be an
idiot with other people too and with
yourself and so if you don't fix the
problem
then you're going to fall into the same
hole repeatedly and what the negative
emotion is is actually an alarm system
telling you that there's a hole and that
is a hole where chaos Reigns where
things are happening that you don't
understand or expect so it's
a it's a prerequisite to further
exploration it's very common in hero
mythology one of the things you see is
that the hero will be on a quest and a
quest is always for the thing that's
valuable and so we're always on a quest
because always with every glance of our
eye we're on a quest and it's very
common in hero mythology which I suppose
represents the larger and more dramatic
quests that when the hero first
encounters the dragon let's say the
monster the giant dragon is usually like
an image is usually an image of the of
nature gone astray and a giant is
usually an image of culture going astray
it and and so those are the two major
quests right to to
confront and reconstitute pathological
structures of adaptation that's sort of
the
anti-patriarchy ethos and then to
confront nature and and Horror in its
base form so a gigantic Dragon would
have aspects of both of those in any
case often when the hero sees the
monster the first time he'll turn tail
and run you see this in the Pinocchio
story for example too Pinocchio goes
down Into the Depths to find God
essentially the god that has died in the
depths in the most chaotic and dangerous
possible place and he's pretty Resolute
in his determination to do that in an
attempt to transform but when he
actually confronts the whale in the
depths initially he like hey a man I'm
out of here you know and that's very
common and you see that you see that
very commonly when an emotion arises
it's the emotional rise it's negative
it's anxious and people's first attempt
is to first reflex is
to say you know this isn't happening to
pretend or to pretend that it's not
necessary to delve into it and then you
might ask well why are people afraid to
delve into it and this is where you can
learn to understand something like
Dante's
Inferno
so if we have an
interpersonal issue let's say it's come
up a couple of time so that I I can be
sure it's there it's not just some
random fluctuation in your mood or that
you're were hungry or that I was hungry
you know something trivial it's happened
a couple of times so I know there's
something there okay well neither of us
are going to want to Broach it
particularly and the reason for that is
that as you delve into something like
that you go into The Inferno so Dante
Illustrated hell nine layers with some
terrible thing which was satanic at the
bottom right sort of evil itself and if
you take any issue that produces
negative of emotion like an issue that
actually exists and you decompose it
completely you'll go all the way to the
bottom right and and part of the reason
for that is
that like anything
threatening is reflective of threat and
vulnerability itself right so it's like
it's a single manifestation of something
Central and a relatively trivial
manifestation maybe there's many but if
you delve into it deeply enough you come
up against the problem per se one of the
things you find with with people if they
have an interpersonal conflict and you
delve deeply into it you often find an
act of betrayal at the bottom someone
betrayed them at some point and they
have a memory of that right and you
could think of that as a semi- trauma
depending on its depth but they'll have
a memory of that and Dante put the
betrayers at the bottom of hell and the
reason he did that was because human
interactions that iter at across time or
dependent on trust and what someone who
betrays you does is entice you to trust
them so they take your best instincts
because trust is a form of courage and
it's a predicate for society and then
they turn it against you right and so
right right right so threat emerges you
get Negative emotion if you deep dig
into it you spiral down down down down
down till you get to the bottom of
things and that's what people say I'm
going to get to the bottom of this right
yeah well Jesus sometimes man that's a
long way down and and people just can't
stand it you know cuz they'll start
talking to each other and they'll go
down one rung at a time and every time
they go down because they're getting
closer to the Ugly Truth more and more
emotion emerges and usually what'll
happen is people will cry or they'll
insult each other or they'll further the
fight or they'll run out of words and
they just stop before they actually
solve the problem it takes a lot of
fortitude to get to the
bottom there was there was so ver so one
more thing Virgil
guides Dante Through The Inferno and
that's a kind of a reflection of the
idea of the Holy Ghost so the Holy Ghost
element of the Trinity the Holy Ghost is
the spirit of truth that's a good way of
thinking about it scientists
who observe their data sets properly are
Guided by the Spirit of Truth otherwise
they they just twist and bend the data
to suit their career for example so
imagine that you're oriented towards the
truth okay so now you have an aim that
calibrates your emotions and it
calibrates your judgment and so if
you're trying to mediate an
interpersonal dispute and you have the
right goal in mind so the right goal
might be peaceful continued productive
generous harmonious existence right then
your emotions will calibrate so you can
tell when the conversation is deviating
from that aim and if you're forthright
in your aim you can use your judgment to
descend down and you can stay oriented
while you're doing it yeah and plus it
isn't so personal then because you've
decided that the aim is truth yeah then
what you bring to truth is uh
subordinate to that and it's it's less
focused on you as an individual because
you are a collective of people who all
made the similar errors over well and
you're also not trying to demonstrate
your moral superiority while trying to
solve the problem because that won't go
over well so that dissent even if it's
between two people has to be a descent
that's predicated on Mutual humility if
you're a therapist for example and
you're guiding someone through that
there's a very high probability that
you're going to encounter all sorts of
terrible things about yourself even as a
therapist while you're walking the
person down that pathway and you have to
do it with especially as you go deeper
and deeper you have to do it with
extreme care and you know you can
imagine that well if you're a therapist
for
example maybe you want to show what a
good therapist you are and so you want
to take over the process you know that's
just a sin of Pride it'll take you off
the course and then especially when you
start to get deeper into things you'll
be in real trouble because the deeper
down you go the higher the price you pay
for any sin that will knock you off the
right path you have to step
carefully if you don't have an air
purifier get one it's like dieting for
your lungs except it's easier than
dieting we're breathing in so many
chemicals mold bacteria mold all the
time and filtering your air is the
laziest thing you can do to clean your
environment so if you're not doing it
there's really no excuse I use AO Oasis
filters all over our house they filter
down to a smaller particle size 0.003
microns than most air purifiers which
makes a massive difference the they're
quiet too I also bought them for scarlet
school to help reduce virus transmission
because little kids are icky they have a
medical grade h13 HEPA filter to trap
dust pollen and smoke aoas I adap air
uses germicidal UV technology to
constantly sterilize itself and the
environment so the filter doesn't get
moldy it has a silver ion filter that
penetrates the cell membrane of mold
bacteria and viruses it reduces
pathogens by up to 99% in the air your
breathing these things also come with
free shipping a lifetime warranty and a
60-day money back guarantee get 10% off
your purchase by using Code MP at
checkout and by going to the link in the
bio which is AER oasis.com
product/ iadapt A- large but that's
linked in the comments enjoy the rest of
this episode there was another question
anyway that had to do with this which
was how do you overcome bitterness and
contempt in a
relationship which is you have to like
you'd have to figure out
every single problem right you'd have to
go down to the bottom with every single
problem Yeah well yeah I think well well
I I would take I would take the most uh
recent the most recent first start with
the recent one the most the most recent
and uh that that stand out for you as
problems so outline all of those and
when you've gone through all of those
then maybe a few months later you'll
want to go again and this time you go
deeper and maybe further back in your
history and so you don't do it I
wouldn't if you did it all at once it
would it be it' be a very long time and
exhaustive it' be too difficult so well
also there'll be classes of problems
like you have to eliminate all of the
issues but that doesn't mean you have to
address every single thing that happened
because there'll be classes of things
that happened and so now so go down
you'll notice that's what going down is
noticing the classes that's exactly it
so imagine there's a lot of individual
occurrences right but then if you go a
level down you can see well these five
occurrences were part of this so now you
go down one level and you see there's
this Clump and this Clump and then you
go down another level and you say oh
these two clumps are this Clump right
well then you can go down this is kind
of what psychoanalysts do instead of
behaviorists the behaviorists will stay
on the periphery and deal with things
one by one like very minute practical
specific issues the psycho will go
deeper and say these 20 things are a
reflection of this underlying concept
which could be implicit or unconscious
because some of this is a delving into
implicit or unconscious structures
sometimes those are revealed in dreams
or in fantasies so you do have to
address everything that's between you in
a relationship but that doesn't mean you
have to go through every bloody thing
that ever happened in the whole
relationship you do have to solve see
the psychoanalyst would have called
those clumps complex
and sometimes when you go down into the
substructure of someone's psyche you'll
find you know that they have a key
problem well with the world like I had
one client for example who really was
paranoid about Authority like really
verging on on true paranoia well when we
got to the bottom of one of her
experiences she told me a story about
having been put in a hospital when she
was five and
being subjected without her parents
being around because at that time
parents weren't allowed to visit their
children in hospitals because the
doctors at least said that they felt
that the continued separation was worse
than just one separation that's so
stupid yeah well it was very
self-serving of the Physicians but in
any case that was her situation she had
a sadistic nurse oh no right so she was
just tortured in the hospital by this
sadistic nurse and so that permanently
destroyed her trust in institutions and
fed a paranoia that infected all of her
relationships yeah I get that so yeah
yeah well sure you can see you can see
exactly how that would happen now
hypothetically if you can go down there
and address that fundamental distrust
then all of
the specific manifestations will also
disappear but it's very complicated
because see as you go down to the
center you're dealing with more and more
archetypal issues so one of the things
you could say about the situation she
was in was that she was archetypically
confronting the evil Uncle of the king
the evil brother of the king so every
hierarchy has a
shadow the shadow is what the left
Wingers always point to it's all about
power it's like no it's only all about
power when it gets corrupt it's a very
important distinction but the claim that
power can corrupt and twist and bend and
that it might even be the primary
dementing phenomenon that's dead on
right well so she encountered a negative
manifestation of authority it's the same
as the evil Uncle it's Scar in The Lion
King fundamentally or the evil advisor
of the like Jafar in in in what is it
Aladdin yeah that character is
everywhere the evil adviser of the king
who wants to be king himself luciferian
intellect usually that utilizes power
well that's what she came up against
when she was
five that nurse used
authority to she sub she she
subordinated authority to whmp she was
sadistic she enjoyed hurting other
people and she used her authority to do
that and so that 5-year-old kid came
face to face with something that's like
Darkly evil and it it that was the
trauma and most people who are
traumatized are traumatized by
malevolence right by by by like the
voluntary desire to hurt she certainly
encountered that she didn't know what to
do about that when she was
so it it really put a warp in her whole
life I feel like like you said a lot of
people encounter this and that's what
traumatizes them what are you at what
point is what you experience reality
though so say I mean there are people in
positions of authority that abuse
authority we've obviously seen that in
the last number of years with the
government overreaching and things uh so
at what point is at what point would you
just view I think I have an issue with
this like if I see people in positions
of authority particularly in the medical
industry the mainstream medical industry
I think you've been taught to think you
know everything and that makes you more
dangerous than the average person right
well what point is that just true more
often than not well that's a constant
that's a constant what would you say uh
challenge to
judgment right I mean the the general
rule
you don't want to throw the baby out
with the bathat this is part of the
problem with populist conservatives you
know when when when a populist
conservative gets up and says all the
institutions are rotten like he's that
far away from like a postmodernist
radical and so you're always separating
the wheat from the chaff in your
evaluation of authority structures and
partly what you do is differentiate them
you know you might say well the whole
medical profession is corrupt but you
don't actually believe that you meet
doctors from time to well
so you have to differentiate your view
and that's you have to become uh you
have to become informed you have to
become more and more informed if you
have that view because the view is
vague right so when I was 17 I was
working in a pool I needed to uh there
was a a rule that was being not followed
there these little kids were too short
to be in the pool so the pool was too
deep and I didn't want want to let them
in without extra people in the pool and
I asked the schools to to give me extra
people and the next week they came and
they didn't bring them and I closed the
pool and the the Town Council called a
meeting and they called me in and they
asked me why I turned the school away
and I told them why weren't you picking
up kids out of the pool yeah well there
were kids that were you know when little
kids can't When anybody can't swim and
they get under the water they just look
at you cuz they don't know what to do to
get back up so they don't move their
limbs they just look at you so here we
were're on the deck going that one's
underwater that one's underwater and I
thought like this is not a good idea and
I'd worked in that pool but I hadn't
worked with these little kids at school
time so I hadn't realized just how deep
it was and how dangerous it was and it
was an old pool built in 1967 when the
last Expo was on they built swimming
pools all through Canada oh yeah in all
the little towns anyway I went to the
town council meeting and I said that I
couldn't run the pool the way that they
wanted me to run the pool I needed this
uh safety measure put in place and they
said uh well they didn't they didn't
think that that was a reasonable request
and uh asked me to just run the pool the
way they wanted to and I said fine you
can sign a paper telling me the way you
want me to run it and I'll go back and
I'll run it that way just to try to
bring it home to them that now Okay so
well one of the coun said said to you he
was annoyed that he was being put on the
spot and he said you'd let some of those
one of those kids drown just to get us
right so and I was 17 and I quit the my
my job because I felt um well I wasay I
felt betrayed right and that betrayal
made caused
cynicism for
government establishments so I didn't
vote I for quite a while I didn't want
anything to do with any government
authority of any kind and that went on
she was always annoyed you know if I
evinced any sort of political ambition
yeah I was and she would say things like
it's all like the small town no I would
say I'm going to become a cartoonist and
do
caricature that that's fine well that
that was amusing but but in the same
vein but it was also to to your point
she was also right yeah like the
corruption she saw at that small town
level that yeah that cynicism that
unwillingness to to think adore well to
adopt proper responsibility the
willingness to throw her under the bus
because this actually became a bit of a
scandal did your dad write the newspaper
no I wrote them and the the mayor wrote
right you and it was published in the
newspaper right right wow yeah yeah yeah
right right so now so but Tammy's
observation that the corruption that she
saw in the local Council was the same as
the corruption at every level was
accurate but the the response isn't well
you know the entire political system is
corrupt and needs to be what violently
overthrown by idiot Rebels or that we
should descend into a state of Anarchy
or that you don't have to take
responsibility on the political front
it's like the evil you said where's the
reality well the reality is the evil
uncle is always there always but then
there's a higher reality than that even
which is the evil uncle that you should
really be concerned about is in Your
Heart Right the place to address that
and this is the one of the fundamental
messages at the highest level of the
judeo-christian ethic I mean it it
definitely points out that worldly power
is subject to corruption but then the
answer to dealing with the corruption
isn't to worry about the corruption the
moat in someone else's eye right it's
like you're probably not
perfect and so if you're concerned about
the political system you should get your
act together and then maybe you could
take requisite political action in a way
that wouldn't be contaminated by power
and and Hedonism right and and the
subordination of everyone else to your
whim but that's a that's an internal
battle you know there's a notion of
jihad in Islam that's like that there's
a Jihad that can be conducted in the
world that's more warlike against the
unbeliever right that can easily
translate into kind of like a
psychopathic War likeness but there's a
spiritual jihad that's an inner battle
that's Akin at least in principle to the
judeo-christian insistence that the
fundamental moral struggle is in the
soul right not in the political
landscape or even deeper that the
political struggles are actually
reflections of battles that should be
conducted in the soul but aren't being
and are then therefore externalized so
in your
marriage you'll hit bumps with with your
husband say that repeat and you might
say well why are there repeating bumps
in my relationship with my husband and
the answer is well there's a knot in
your soul or in his that hasn't been
untied and so because the person in
whose soul that knot exists hasn't taken
the time to untangle it it makes itself
manifest in the world as conflict and
that is how it
works and so it's it's useful and this
is this has to do with prayer I suppose
with confession as well one of the
things that's very useful if you're
fighting with your whoever your daughter
your brother your sister your your wife
you want to figure out what the hell
you're bringing to it you know and you
don't do that in a false humility I'm
parading my moral virtue because I'm so
good at discovering my flaws sort of way
it's like you got to be afraid of that
in the proper way it's like do you want
to have this fight a thousand times
or do you want to fix it and if you
think through what it means to have the
fight a thousand times you get family
relationships that are poisoned for
decades because people won't cuz you it
you your children that the way to act
yeah through your actions and if your
actions are filled with say resentment
and so that
you're that that's what you're showing
your kids are learning that oh this is
this is the way
my mom's relationship is with her sister
so that's that's a family relationship
oh so then they start looking you know
it start imitating it just it just keeps
going and going and going you don't you
don't want that to go down the
generations like stop it
now
yeah I'm going to pick something more
[Laughter]
positive look it is positive it is it is
positive I know it's weird but the thing
is this is the weird thing about let's
let's say
confession you can regard the discovery
of a devil in your soul as a treasure
because if you find something that
you're really doing wrong and you
actually understand that it's wrong
first of all you'll understand why you
did it in the past and that's not
nothing but more importantly you can
shed it and so it's a very it's one of
these moral inversions you know like
there's an insistence in the gospel
texts in particular that the highest
serves the lowest that there's a strange
relationship between the highest and the
lowest and one of those strange
relationships is
that in a in a sense there shouldn't be
anything more exciting than the
discovery of your like the conscious
discovery of your own
insufficiency because then you can
address it and like if you got really
good at that what that would mean is
you'd be getting rid of everything that
is causing you trouble and God only
knows what your life could be like if
you got rid of everything that you could
get rid of right that's a sacrif that's
proper sacrifice and you have to
be well that's where humility comes in
it's like probably a lot of me needs to
go and but in the back of your mind
should also be well that's probably
better than all of
me just think of all the new going right
that's right that's right exactly that
yeah yeah what happens when you're freed
from
that yeah that's the that's the res
ction in the death
mhm I think it took me cuz you both like
told Julian and I when we were little
like tell the truth that's the most
important thing you can do is tell the
truth but it's really hard to understand
and even having you guys as parents it's
still really hard to understand
especially if you tell the truth and you
get in trouble as a kid because then
it's pretty obvious like well this
doesn't seem to be going well um before
you can really think about it or see any
long-term repercussions I think it
wasn't until I was and then so I was
probably I I probably knew more solidly
that it was important to tell the truth
by the time my brain developed I was
probably 23 where I was like no I've
seen the repercussions of
lying telling the truth is important but
then I didn't realize that also not
saying what you thought was also not
telling the truth so then it took
another it took another
like four years
maybe so maybe 27 to be like oh okay
also all the thoughts I have that I'm
not saying that is also not telling the
truth and those also matter like just as
much or more yeah and so yeah the most
common sin like classically speaking the
church has held that sins of commission
are more important than are more uh
deadly let's say than sins of omission
so like an outright falsehood is more
deadly than Aid voiding the truth but
I'm I'm very I don't know torn about
that because totally depends what it is
well it it does but but the problem with
a sin of omission is they're a lot
easier to rationalize yeah it's like
well I don't have to say anything it's
like maybe I'd hurt people well you
don't run the whole you don't run the
whole simulation when you say something
like that well I don't really have to
say anything you don't think I don't
really have to say anything but I'll be
bitter and resentful and I'll play the
role of martyr for the next three
decades like you just truncate that
right and so then you're not even
viewing the severity of the avoidance
and and you're right about what kids do
this is why everyone lies so people lie
to gain things that they don't deserve
to gain and they lie to avoid paying a
price that they need to pay that's
probably mostly what I did was to avoid
I was just avoiding things that I
thought were bad whenever I lied it was
just avoiding like well and it's a
short-term strategy and it works in the
short term which is part of the reason
that it's so attractive kind of it makes
you feel bad well that's because it
violates your conscience right yeah and
your conscience you could think of your
conscience in part as the Instinct that
calibrates the medium to the long run so
let's say you have to admit that you did
something wrong because you're being
called on it by your parents and there's
going to be trouble and now you lie and
you avoid the trouble well you violate
the conscience because the conscience is
has learned it's an instinct as well
well it's calibrating the medium to long
run and so it knows that you sacrific
the medium to long run for the present
that in in your conscience that's like a
definition of what conscience does it
always says to you you sacrifice the
higher to the lower right so that's a
false sacrifice that's the kind of
sacrifice that Cain makes constantly and
that's why he gets that's why his life
goes to hell you're called upon imagine
there's a hierarchy of value with
something at the Pinnacle right and
there always is cu even when you're just
looking at a specific object there's
something at the Pinnacle you're always
organizing your perceptions and actions
around an name you're
always climbing up a mountain of one
form or another always
always
the the rule is if you if you're in a
hierarchy of value that you sacrifice
what's lower to what's higher that's the
nature of progress a false sacrifice is
the reverse and
conscience will tell you when you're
making a false sacrifice because it says
well you might have skirted some trouble
temporarily but you're no longer
climbing up the proper Mountain so yeah
so I've been I've been playing in in we
who wrestle with God in this new book
that I'm writing I've been playing with
the relationship between what's sacred
and emotion playing I suppose the border
between biology and Theology and so one
of the ways that God makes himself manif
EST in the Old Testament in particular
is as a calling so you can imagine that
there are things that grip your interest
and make you
enthusiastic right and and they they
have a kind of autonomy because you find
that you're interested in something or
you discover it and it grips you and you
can go along with that and you can
follow that when I wrote maps of meaning
that was what I concentrate on most I
have a chapter in there called the
Divinity of interest and I was
developing the idea that one of the
Golden Threads that orients you in your
life is things that interest you that's
the burning bush by the way things that
grip your interest you can follow them
and they'll Lead You uphill but what
I've come to understand now because
there was no role for negative emotion
in that God is like the dynamic
interplay between the calling and
conscience so the calling says come this
way towards the greatest treasure right
the treasure is in this direction and
that'll make itself manifest in
different places for different people
even though it's all pointing to the
same thing but conscience comes along
for the ride and says you're deviating
from the path you're deviating from the
path and so God is the call of
conscience and the and the calling it's
the interplay between those two things
and I'm I'm bringing that up because
people they say well I you know there's
no evidence for God you know I can't
find God God is dead God has disappeared
it's like well you're just you don't see
the
manifestation and you might say well why
call that God it's like well try to
escape from your
conscience and then try to make yourself
interested in things you're not
interested in you can't do that there's
an autonomy about it and it is it a
Living
spirit at some point questions like that
devolve into a matter of definition but
it's definitely those are both animating
Spirits the conscience and calling are
both animating Spirits so for all
intents and purposes not only are they
alive they're Immortal and every and and
they're shared by everyone so I suppose
atheists would just write that off and
say that's an evolutionary
adaptation right but the problem order
to thrive or it's not but yeah but it's
not a write off I say that's fine have
it your way it's like oh so what you're
saying is that those two Spirits Orient
you towards like thriving in maximum
reproductive Fitness it's like okay same
I don't care have it your way the the
Practical consequences and even the
metaphysical consequences are identical
we could take the biological perspective
it's like fair enough okay so that
reflects something fundamental about the
nature of
being yeah come to it evolutionarily
okay doesn't matter it doesn't matter
these things dovetail and look we do
even scientists assume that there's an
ultimate unity it's it's part of the
presumption of the western Enterprise of
science is that in the final analysis
there's a Unity of comprehension there's
a Unity of ethic and and material
reality evolutionary biology and
theology will dovetail if they're both
laid out correctly they'll dovetail and
I think we're very close to that now
very very close to that if if not
already having attain that if you
haven't checked out my anti-hangover
pill Afterparty check it out at Fuller
health.com it helps reduce the negative
impact of alcohol on your brain and body
and even if you don't drink often which
you shouldn't really it should be
something that's part of your Wellness
routine that you just have at your house
if you ever decide to have a glass of
wine or more it reduces symptoms of
nausea anxiety shakiness and even helps
a bit with sleep deprivation because it
works on Gaba mostly it works by
breaking down aalah hiide which is what
poisons you when you drink if you do
like this product please leave a review
at Fuller health.com I love reading the
reviews code mp15 for 15% off enjoy the
rest of this episode you know when kids
are small and they go to public school
they're taught to learn all they're
taught to learn math they're taught to
learn social studies they're taught to
learn all these different things and to
take enough uh the same amount of
interest in everything that EV that they
have to be doing well in all the
different areas but I've been reading
about uh interest based education where
you just follow what they want to do
that what they're not what they want to
do but what they what gives them meaning
so if a kid is really drawn to math or
really Drawn to Art or whatever it is
that you capitalize on that and that
bringing and keeping that all alive
that's what guides you well it it's
certainly so there's an upside and a
downside to that so the upside is that
if you can find out what someone is
spontaneously interested in they're
motivated yeah right and the reason
they're motivated you don't kill the
rest of everything because you're making
them do things that is more difficult
for them well that's that's that's right
well what happens if if you use force is
that you you decrease positive
motivation yeah Skinner showed that very
clearly with animals which is why he
preferred using reward to punishment so
you get all sorts of Kickbacks if you
use Force so there was a big movement in
the 1960s to orient schools around a
child's interest and that turned into
child- centered learning and that was
one of the pathways to like the
postmodern catastrophe in education but
I think part of the reason for that was
that if you you can't pursue interest
without taking into account conscience
it's too positive right there's no
Shadow to it right and so and I don't
know exactly what that
means I don't know exactly how to
integrate those things like I said well
maybe with interest you have to go very
deeply into it very well you have to do
in a disciplined way well you do well so
in in this in The Exodus story when
Moses encounters the burning bush he's
just doing his normal day-to-day
Shepherd thing right he's pretty happy
his life's going pretty well but
something beckons to him from the side
it glimmers and and and and and gleams
and so he goes to investigate it and as
he investigates it he gets closer and
closer to it so you can imagine he's
getting deeper and deeper into it right
as he pays attention he eventually
realizes he's on sacred ground and he
takes off his shoes so as he pursues
what he's interested in and he gets
deeper into it he understands that he's
approaching what's sacred what's most
fundamental right what's what's at the
Pinnacle or what's at the base either
metaphor works and but he continues in
his Pursuit and eventually the voice of
God speaks to him and that's when he
becomes a leader and he's an archetypal
leader because he stands up against
tyranny and against slavery and so the
moral of the story is is that if you
pursue what you're what calls to you
with enough integrity and discipline you
will get to the the bottom of things and
that will make you a leader now it's a
weird the Moses story has got an
interesting twist in it too because God
speaks from the depths of the burning
bush and tells Moses that he has to go
back to Egypt and confront the Pharaoh
so now he has to go after the evil Uncle
that's a good way of thinking about it
and Moses said oh I can't do this and
God says well why not and and Moses says
well you picked the wrong guy and God
says well you know I know who's the
right guy so what do you mean and Moses
said well I'm like T tied I have a
speech impediment I can't speak and God
basically says he says something
approximating maybe two things that's
your problem figuring it out figure it
out but there's another implication
there which
is everybody is going to have something
wrong with them in relationship to the
pursuit of what's best so standing up
against tyranny in a given like I'm not
smart enough I'm not attractive enough
I'm not charismatic enough you know I'm
I'm I'm I'm not resilient enough I don't
have enough money yeah I I don't have
enough influence like there's going to
be impediments
and God's response is I don't care what
your impediment are you can overcome
them that's right well and it you know
it it isn't also necessarily a weakness
you know because it's something you have
to contend with but it's going to be
something that a lot of other people
share now the way Moses deals with it is
he enlists his brother Aaron so this is
another great lesson it's like your job
is to go stand up against tyranny and to
rescue yourself and other people from
the habits of slaves and to move towards
the promised land and there's a bunch of
things about doing that that you're
going to be pretty useless at and so you
should recognize them but then in
recognizing them something else happens
which is very interesting which is
there's a lot of other people around you
know you could you could enlist their
services and then there's something for
everyone else to do and that's also a
really useful thing to know to take the
kind of Messianic Mania out of that
archetypal idea like if you're seized
with the idea that you have this Mission
you know to free the world from tyranny
and to and to decrease people's slavish
habits then that's all on you well
that's a crushing responsibility it's a
pathway to kind of manic
grandiosity right but if you understand
that that's true for you but it's not
true for you Al alone and that there's
plenty of things along the way for
absolutely everyone else to do with the
same degree of seriousness well then
you've got the equation approximately
right and that can also help you like if
you're running an organization it's like
it's okay if other people have important
things to do too there's no you are not
going to run out of important things to
do no matter how many you distribute to
other people there's going to be plenty
of things for you to do right and so
that's such a relief to know that yeah I
learned that about 20 years ago I guess
you know because I'd been dealing with
the problem of evil for a long time and
it felt like a crushing responsibility
especially as I came to understand it
more and more deeply and I thought well
I have an understanding that appears to
be in some ways I wouldn't say unique
but unique enough so that when I'm
sharing it it has a effect on people
thought well I don't know you know like
what am I supposed to do about that that
seems like too much to deal with and it
was at that time too that I realized
it's like well if it's too much for you
to deal with you're not sharing the
responsibility enough like by definition
by definition and you know that you've
built organizations is that as you scale
them up oh you can't grow that's because
you do reach your capacity right and you
you just you cannot grow unless you
unlist help with for with other people
and then what you want to do is you want
to so I talked to uh Frank stach about
running Magna you know he keeps his
Factories at a certain size I think it's
2 or 400 I don't remember which but what
he does is he separate he sets people up
with their own independent fathoms he
says this is yours it's 90 like we're
still Associated but this is your thing
and like if you can make it great and
you can grow wonderful that's not it's
not a zero sum game and that's a lovely
thing to understand too it's very
generous it's a you can operate in the
world in very generous fashion once you
realize that here's something else
that's cool you know I worked with Bob
Peele for years Bob was a great graduate
supervisor and he there was a real
contrast between him and many other
professors because Bob was 100% generous
with his ideas like I'd go into his
office and talk to him and I did that
like twice a week we talked a lot and we
would share ideas and I can generate
plenty of ideas but Bob could generate
plenty of ideas and he didn't care what
happened to his
ideas and if he had a graduate student
who grabbed an idea and then you know
came up with an experiment ran with that
then they got the authorship and that
helped develop their career and but
here's something cool and and you can
you this just makes perfect sense so
imagine there's a biological process
that's operating within me that's
generating ideas okay now and it can
grow or Shrink okay if it's rewarded
it's going to grow and if it's going to
grow it's going to produce more ideas
and if it's punished it's going to
shrink okay so now my attitude is I have
no faith in that Source fundamentally I
think it's
exhaustible and so now I'm stingy as
hell with my ideas and partly that makes
other people suspicious and doubtful and
so every time I share an idea something
negative happens well do that for 5
years and even if you had the goose that
laid the golden eggs to begin with it's
not laying any
eggs by contrary by contrast you're a
creative person you just give those
ideas away freely and you get a
tremendously positive response that's a
very rewarding response all that does is
make that capacity grow and all that
happens is that you produce way more
ideas that's why Christ says that he's a
well that's inexhaustible
fundamentally that's that's what that's
pointing to is
that you can't deplete what you have by
sharing it
properly quite the contrary the better
you are at sharing what you've been
what's been granted to you as a gift a
talent the better you are at sharing
that the more it's going to thrive and
that's a great thing to know too because
like you couldn't want a better solution
than that I think I think I I agree with
that in the mostly I think the
skepticism I have is I really don't like
to see people and this might be I just
realized this a couple days ago cuz you
worked with some people and you had a
brilliant idea and you kind of gave it
to them and they just just like took
advantage of you and wrecked the idea
basically and I think I and I don't know
how much that impacted me but I thought
about it a couple days ago so it must
have impacted me a bit I don't like well
it was very unpleasant yeah and I don't
like like I think you have to be careful
about who you give your ideas to cuz I
don't like seeing beautiful ideas taken
by narcissistic people and
destroyed that's the Pearl problem and
the so Christ tells his followers that
they have to be as soft as doves
essentially and as wise as serpents and
like there is it's it's also in biology
that's the that's the cheater problem
fundamentally if you have a community of
Cooperators and you drop in one
shark the the shark will take
everything and that's the psychopath
problem in biology as well and so you do
have to share
with judgment you have to share wisely
and you have to be willing you also have
to share without ego and without Pride
because if your sharing is full of then
you you won't share in the right moments
with the right people well you're also
likely to attract more than your fair
share of of Psychopathic responses that
way too because if people see that
you're sharing for your own
self-interest and they're the sort of
people who are likely to do that they
see your behavior as justification for
what or get good people coming but it
doesn't go well because it wasn't the
right moment for them to even find yeah
you can't be there's a big difference
between being generous and being naive
like it's a tricky and there's a big
difference between being courageously
trusting and naive you know so part of
the way that I've conceptualized that
and this is very useful for people
naivity looks like virtuous
innocence but it's not it's just naivity
when you're you're if you're naive you
will be burned and you'll be burned to
some degree by someone malevolent right
so then what happens is you go from
naivity to
cynicism and it's hard for you to give
up your cynicism because there's an
element of it that's wiser than the
naivity and going back to being naive is
just like going back to being an infant
it's not an improvement it's a
deterioration even though the naivity
was trustful and so forth and it wasn't
it was just naive
naivity cynicism
courageous Faith right and so courageous
faith is I'll cooperate with you and
maybe I'll even do it repeatedly but I'm
going to keep my eyes open and I know
perfectly well that there are snakes
around right but that but but the
Transcendence of the cynicism is once
you understand that the snakes are there
then you think well I could there's just
snakes everywhere I shouldn't trust
anyone I should be contemptuous and
doubtful about all institutions and
that's wiser than
naivity especially if it's hard-earned
if if the knowledge is hard-earned but
it's not the optimized response the
optimized and this has been
mathematically modeled as well too like
because one of the questions is what
pattern
best maximizes the utility across
repeated social interactions and one
answer to that is tit fortat you and I
are going to play a game I start I trust
you I open myself up to betrayal you
could betray me and gain a short-term
gain you don't you trust me and then we
get the thing going now what happens if
you betray me the best response is I
whack you with proportionate force and
then I open the door to cooperation
again that's no one has come up there's
small modifications of that but no one
has come up with a strategy that works
better in repeated social interactions
than essentially tit fortat tit fortat
with with with a bias
towards no initial cooperation guy named
Robert Axelrod figured this out he was
interested in the emergence of
Cooperative strategies because it really
is quite a mystery right if if you're in
a distrustful
situation and you distrust me so you so
you're not going to act positively to me
and I distrust you so I'm not going to
act positively towards you then our
responses justify our doubt how do we
get out of that and how many times do
you play that game with somebody when
they betray you like how many chances do
people get cuz like when you're a busy
person and you have more to lose like is
it once or is it twice because I don't
think it's three times is quite a few
times that's quite a was of time my rule
the rule that Tammy and I have used in
our relationship at least to some degree
too is like well you know when you're
interacting with each other constantly
there's going to be variations and
irritability you know and so maybe
she'll say something to me and I'm
Snappy and we could do the whole Dante's
Inferno thing or we could think well you
know maybe he's hungry or tired or and
so you have to have some level of
writing it off you know and and and A
good rule and I did this with my clients
too was like if someone trips over you
at work once it's noise it's not data
twice it's like then maybe you raise an
eyebrow three times you've established a
pattern okay right and then you can go
to the person well it's also way more
effective as a negotiating strategy
because then you can go to the person
and you can say this happened yesterday
and their first response
is no it didn't or you're imagining
things but then you say well yeah I
thought so too but it also happened here
and it also happened here and it's like
the probability that the person can
weasle out of that then is like it's
virtually zero and then you can have the
then you can have the conversation now
you can't get too finger Waggy about you
did this three times because then
there's that moral superiority and the
thing the reason you don't want to do
that is because you just don't know why
the person is doing that you know I I
talked to this guy in my podcast just
quite recently
who he was going to shoot up a school
when he was a high school student yeah
yeah and that's pretty bad and so and
it's obviously unforgivable but
but if you listen to his
life you would understand how he got
there now but isn't that the same for
everyone like there aren't I mean do you
know of any evil like evil people or
people who do evil things don't have
reason yeah but not everybody goes
through immense amounts of suffering and
then turns into a psychopath Yeah well
yeah no that's definitely true there's
always reasons for people to be evil but
it's you can't use those for for reasons
to be evil no no well and that's well
and I think too it's like that's sort of
the victim perpetrator yeah border it's
like at some point you go from victim
justifiably so let's say to perpetrator
it's also not that useful to constru
yourself as a victim no matter what
happens to you everyone's a freaking
victim well they they're alive life is
hard yeah do you remember in grade four
when we were learning about bullies I
remember at the time I didn't even like
this we're learning about bullies and
what we learned was well if somebody's
bullying you it's because their life is
so hard that that's why they're bullying
you and you should be nice to them and I
was like what I think I also had you
know I was really sick things was like
hard life I know people have hard lives
like they they have hard lives doesn't
mean you get to be mean to everybody
around you right right absolutely yeah
yeah cuz you were taught that you
couldn't use your illness for an
excuse really for anything it's also
hard to beat up people if you have
arthritis yeah it is maybe I couldn't I
didn't have the option to go down no
that's not true because that's not
really how girls bully anyway well I
think hardship is a it's a challenge
it's a challenge to overcome hardship
that's what it is doesn't matter what
well and hardship can make you virtuous
just like it can make you vicious
certainly well that's why there's such
an insistence in the western
philosophical ethos on Free Will there's
no deter n knew this too he said any any
situation SU to a multitude of
interpretations like there's a
postmodern element to that but there's
also you say well he was beat up as a
kid and that's why he beats as kids well
first of all most people beat as
children do not beat their kids and you
can think figure that out mathematically
because if child abuse was deterministic
it would spread yeah and everyone would
do it and it isn't spread it's dampened
and so if you are an abuser there's a
higher than average chance that you were
abused as a kid but if you were abused
as a kid the overwhelming probability is
that you won't abuse your children right
exactly so It's Tricky right because if
you go into the history of someone who's
Psychopathic and they tell you their
life story and they're not lying you
think oh my God it's no wonder but then
you know you meet someone like Charles
Joseph who yeah was just tortured to
death in 50 different ways and decided
clearly decided that you know he was
going to do everything he could to let
that go certainly not to visit it on his
children and to try to live a virtuous
life you know like everyone backslides
and when you backslide and you've been
hurt very badly you backslide into you
know martyrdom and resentment and no
bloody Wonder but that doesn't mean it's
deterministic how can you tell when
someone really loves you well it's in
it's in the marriage
vows through sickness and through Health
right through riches and through poor
and if you're not going to stay through
those
trials then there's no left there if you
don't want
to if you don't want to stay well it's a
decision if it's also a decision like
when when we took our vows it was
serious so it was a it was a solemn
occasion because I I meant it it was
like and I I Knew by that time more or
less what that meant it's a hell of a
thing to
say
but and I knew that partly from Yung you
know he believed that you couldn't make
a marriage work without the commitment
the like the real full out commitment
because you can just run away from each
other then you can't solve your problems
if you can run
away if the doors open cuz at some point
you'll encounter a marriage problem that
looks like the problem is worse than
getting
divorced like that'll happen and so if
divorce is an option you just won't
solve the problem and the problem is is
that there's a problem of that size in
virtually every
relationship I mean that's the problem
of Satan fundamentally like there's just
no getting
away those problems come up though if
you don't pursue what's meaningful in
your life if you have sins of omission
if you do all those things then that is
the consequence of that is that you'll
find yourself in a place where you think
maybe divorce is easier so you don't
want to go there you want to take care
things every week but then at at what
point is divorce easier I feel like
because there is a point but then but
then I feel like okay so with my
experience maybe if you get to that
point it's because you didn't know the
person very
well there's lots of reasons you can get
to that point and you know I had lots of
clients who yeah chose the path of
divorce and they often chose the path of
divorce we had family members too oh yes
definitely when when they couldn't
negotiate with their partner now there's
all sorts of reasons you might not be
able to negotiate with your partner one
would be you're not skilled enough as a
negotiator another would be they're
actually not interested in the or you're
not suitable you're just not suitable
your personalities are such that you
know my sister was pretty I think she's
probably pretty agreeable and her
husband was super disagreeable kind of a
loner and he didn't negotiate at all and
they and they grew apart yeah that's
often that often splits men and women
you'll get an agreeable man woman who's
quite feminine and a disagreeable man
who's quite masculine and they just
there's no grounds to communicate you
know the guy just
goes you know and maybe he's not very
articulate you know and there's no
moving him and maybe he doesn't even
know how to negotiate because people
Christ people are so bad at negotiating
it's just a miracle and it's not
surprising cuz negotiation is sort of
the opposite of a sin of omission yeah
if you're negotiating you have to
confront all the things you want to
avoid right now and no one wants that
it's so annoying it's like if I'm
negotiating with Tammy I have to listen
to our problems you know and it's it's
ways you're just to not want to bother
with that but the the problem with that
is the problems are there so like I can
wish that they weren't there all I want
but that is going to make them go away
so it's way better just to and I really
don't like it no but you practice with
things we practice with little things
daily things that we negotiate and then
if you have to negotiate something
that's deep and Troublesome at least
you've practiced some of it maybe you
can do it then see I know that she that
she loves me to the degree that she
plays
along and that's a good definition you
know when I went to when we went to um
Florence Tammy went to Florence to do a
uh sight sizing course in Renaissance
art well I played
along like
wholeheartedly well why well that's like
a definition of love you you play along
with the person you love and play is the
right metaphor and we've discovered that
more and more especially in the
aftermath of our illnesses like we're
we're bet we've always been pretty good
at playing along with each other because
we played together as kids like that's a
pretty standard pattern yeah that help
probably yeah definitely definitely we
we learned that we could play along with
each other when we were very little and
that was very very positive thing and
that was disrupted in teenagehood for
you know any number of reasons
but you know we've had very serious
conversations in the last few years and
one of the things we've made even more
clear to each other is like she can do
whatever she wants I am not interested
in getting in her way in the least if I
can figure out where she's headed and I
can do something to help her with that
I'm going to do that and I'm going to
assume that will doil with what I'm
doing and she's playing along with me
and you know we we have a weird life and
and it's an unbelievable life in many
ways and but and we come together now
and then and
think you know are we going to continue
with this particular game and like she's
a Tammy's always been up for an
adventure so
you
love is the highest form of
play that's
true that was
nice well we had to get something
positive didn't we yeah yeah a little
bit Yeah well you can tell when you can
tell when Love Is in the Air because the
spirit of play is what's dominating one
one of the things we've been practicing
too like
consciously when we came back together
after we were so ill that was quite comp
complicated cuz we'd Grown Apart and I
was still very very ill when I moved
home and it was even worse than that
because I was in terrible shape in the
mornings and then I got like more or
less at least to the point of subhuman
by 10:00 at night and I was sort of you
could stand being around me and by that
time her clock was exactly the opposite
and she was ready for bed so that made
things complicated and you know we came
back together around our practice of
dating
and that really worked and that also
indicated to us that the core of our
relationship was still intact and you
know and then my health started to
improve and that made things a lot
easier but like one of the things that
we've been striving to do consciously is
to con conceptualize the best of our
romantic interactions our dates our
dancing our playing and to see if we can
do that all the time right to expand
that outward so that our attitud to
where every day
is that every day like every minute that
you spend together could be the perfect
date if you oriented yourself properly
at least that's a hell of a good goal
and to spread that out to your community
right right well right right if you can
do that well to your family at large and
to your friends and you know yeah and
there's definitely Spirit play yeah
right cuz we were driving down the road
and I was thinking ah well we had a
little accident a couple years ago so
now I'm a little bit more tentative
about being in the car and so I thought
so one day I just said let's try to
bring that Spirit of play to the car to
drive me and my spirit was like hellbent
to the next destination right with every
ounce of intensity I could muster and
and so like I'm pretty much pushing the
limit on the road all the time because I
do that all the time and and then I
thought
well oh probably I could replace that
for the extra two minutes I was going to
gain certainly now in particular I mean
when I was younger I think there was
probably more rationale for Flatout
intensity but even then that's that's
better than being useless but it's not
optimized right right Spirit of play is
better I I think you can tell generosity
I think you can tell when people love
you whether whether that's like family
or significant other if you can
talk to them about your problems and
show them who you are without putting on
any type of act and have them still
enjoy being around you or like that
better than whatever act you're putting
on you don't have to hide parts of
yourself for them to love you no so it's
pretty it's pretty obvious when somebody
loves you you don't have to be somebody
else you don't have to be the person
they would love if if you were them
yeahh yeah well they the vows are a
safety net around that too right because
there'll be times when you're oh when
you're not you well also when you have
to reveal things that you know aren't
particularly lovable even to you and if
you have to keep those hidden you know
and that's complicated you can't grow
and learn if you have to keep them
hidden no but sometimes you you can have
done things in your life that are so
bloody egregious that it really is a
shock to the other person like the kind
of you know that's especially the case
say if you've had an
affair yeah you know how do you how do
you bring that to the other person's
attention without de demolishing the
relationship generally you can't well we
haven't had that yeah well we haven't
learned about that that's good so I
don't know what to say about that really
don't do it that's what I think play
with your wife well that's the simple
that's the simplest yeah right right
right right well that's another issue
with sins of omission too you know it's
like there's an
archetypal there's
archetypal representation of women you
might say that men fall back on when
they're not differentiated one would be
virgin and the other would be
right and wife gets put in the Virgin
category right because who wants to have
a for a wife at least that's the
shallow conception and the answer is
well actually sometimes that is what you
want but then you have to violate your
Purity norm and you have to let some of
the female element of this category into
this category and men have a real hard
time with that so they put their wife on
a pedestal and she has to be pure and
you know virgin mother type and then
that doesn't work because that's an
insufficient it's not what they want
either context is everything let's put
it that way right there's a time and a
place for everything right and so
they'll go looking for the horror
elsewhere you know and then then there
were women who just act that out and you
know that's not good for them o
obviously either because then they just
end up used and discarded and cynical
and Psychopathic and bitter and and
ruined and that's not a good so you know
you know Tammy mentioned playing is like
you want to incorporate that other
element into your relationship so that
that's also satisfied and you have to
admit what you want and that's very
frightening for people especially it's
often frightening sexually for people
because that's in that's where you're
most naked so to speak right so that's
where people's vulnerabil ities are
really they're right there and so people
won't even admit to themselves what they
want and then that even makes it worse
because if you have sexual desires that
you don't admit to that are real as you
refuse to interact with them they get
bitter and resentful they get twisted
they get twisted oh yeah they get
twisted and grow into all sorts of
monstrous underground forms and then you
really that we know anything about that
yeah okay I I I think we wrap this up by
here giv give people a brief overview of
what 2024 looks like for you for you
both but why don't you
start what are we doing going on a tour
huge tour right yeah huge tour for mon
so why did you agree to that um well you
have a new book mhm so this will mean
new lectures so this will mean new ideas
when is that coming out probably
November but we're going to talking
about it right away y so people are
going to hear the ideas yeah before the
book comes out so that means I have to
think of new things to talk about so
that's challenging yeah and and we're
going to have people travel with us P
has already agreed to Jonathan Pas we're
trying to get Douglas Murray to come
along too like he did in Europe he's
interested but he has Visa trouble for
the US so right we'll see if we can
arrange that but there's other people
need to come along too and then we have
friends that travel with us so that and
so it isn't as lonely and we're going to
be in the states and we know lots of
people in the well and you also changed
up the tour we did but it was really
under your influence so what did you do
differently well we have spread out so
we have three shows in a row and then we
have four days and then we have three
shows yeah otherwise it's just not
doable I don't think it's doable so
we're going to try this out and see if
this four days that we have available
takes care of the time we need off the
time we need to have dinners with people
podast podcasts and stuff and our
relationship being able to see the
places we're in you know it was
we've done it for 5 years but what we're
trying to do one of the things that
people need to understand is that if
something really good is happening to
you one of the things you should think
through very carefully is first of all
you should notice this is unlikely this
good fortune and then you should think
okay what impediments are there in the
path of this iterating that would
accumulate across time you know and
we've had to work that out on the tour
because it got too intense tense at
times and at some point you think well
we I just won't do this anymore but then
when you have an opportunity like this
that's an insane conclusion right
because it's so unlikely and it's so
positive that what that means is you
didn't make the right sacrifices along
the way and so now you have to sacrifice
the whole damn thing and so you know
we've negotiated along the whole way and
I've tried to listen very carefully to
Tammy too to see what has to be modified
so that she's enthusiastically on board
you know that meant modifying the
schedule that schedule was crazy I mean
I opened for you guys I a couple years
ago for like a month and I was working
at the same time which was and it was
not doable like this isn't even it was
fun it was really exciting but I was
exhausted in New City every day MH so a
flight every day oh man so I think I was
on a bus at that point so I didn't have
to do the flight but the bus is easier
um but I think the 4day off we'll see
how that goes we'll see how that goes
and we're going to go to South America
so the 50 cities are in the US we're
going to go to Central and South America
for a week oh cool that's in June June
oh that's fun
maybe and then we're going to be at our
cottage for most of the summer and fall
that's the plan and the fall is still
indeterminate apart from the fact that
the book is coming out plus we're
launching Peterson Academy in February
and so that's a that's a big deal and
this Ark Enterprise that has got
underway in London will unfold we're
planning some Regional events major
regional events next year likely in the
United States possibly in the Middle
East so that's exciting um we're going
to do a conference yeah we're going to
do a conference next fall yeah for
Peterson
Academy yeah I think so Peterson Academy
but we're still still figuring it out
we're going to do a conference for sure
and under what rubric remains to be
determined oh I see right so and I'm
very much looking forward to I'm just
about finished my book and two books
actually because it's going to be two
books um and I'm very excited about that
so it's I've had the most fun writing
this book of any books I've written and
it's come easiest and I think I got the
balance I wrote maps of meaning it's
very hard then I wrote 12 rules and
Beyond order and they're more publicly
accessible this one is kind of somewhere
in the middle it's harder for sure it's
denser but it's easier to understand
than maps of meaning and I think that
it'll be revelatory that's that's the
idea I don't I cannot see that people
will read this book and understand it
and like I think it'll demolish the
atheistic argument Dem his atheism I
guess well happened a long time ago oh I
see but that would be
wild well you can see it happening
already because you know there are
people like iyan hery Ali and Neil
Ferguson and Douglas Murray who have
come to e either like full-fledged
acceptance of a theistic Viewpoint or at
minimum a deep understanding of the fact
that like a moral humanistic Endeavor in
the absence of an underlying
metaphysical Foundation isn't that isn't
it has no staying power it's weak it's
it's going to be blown over immediately
by ideology by competing religious
claims by by new spontaneous religious
forms veganism or vegetarianism or
climate yeah or nature worship that's
right the climate thing like that's
become pretty obvious so I'm very
excited about and that's partly why
we're also so happy to be going on tour
because it's going to be very
interesting to
see the response and you know it's good
that we can still do our podcast cuz I
really like doing my podcast yeah yours
has been doing learning a lot I really
like speaking you've done how many oh I
don't know over yeah you're going to
surpass me well you've been busy oh my
gosh yeah you've been busy too
you baby makes really busy yeah it does
it does not that busy well and you've
had well that's another thing that's
sort of on the table for you we're going
to go back to Italy and both of us are
much are interested in pursuing Artistic
Endeavors to a much greater degree than
we have and like that's something that
beckons in the future for me and for you
um I told you we're going to find out
you've made money through touring and
through your books and things but you're
going to be an artist and that's
actually what's going to be the most
valuable thing you do that'd be pretty
funny that would be pretty funny that
would be funny I can certainly see that
it would be the most fun I mean I've had
such a good time making music and that's
been just a blast and Tammy and I have
both really really enjoyed that we have
really good people to work with so
that's been ridiculously fun so I could
imagine doing that for like 10 years in
music videos yeah nice and well and I
wrote a screenplay on on Brothers Grim
story and Marshall and I and Tammy and
Sonia and and Victor have recorded five
or six six or seven songs for that and
so Marshall's already put them together
so and it's getting easier and easier to
make a movie not that that's necessarily
a good thing but more straightforward
thing for me especially if I want to do
something at so you know that's more
like a three-year plan
so so all good things yeah good things
that's right grandkids good things yeah
yeah well in our various Enterprises
like I enjoy working with Julian on
essay and that's going very nicely and
we're having quite a blast with our
various Ventures and Peterson Academy
it's going to be huge well it's an
adventure I mean you know I'm very happy
with the way it's going and so
congratulations on that I think you've
done a bang up job and we have excellent
professors and they're all thrilled to
be parti everybody seems very happy oh
and I have we have the gospel seminar
coming up in beginning of April right
and so everybody's on board with that
because they were we had a great time
when we did The Exodus seminar everybody
loved it and so I everyone I invited
back said you know tell me when it's
going to happen and I'll be there and
the daily wire has been very
enthusiastic about it and so I'm really
looking forward to that because I walk
through the gospels in great detail
writing this book gospels will be fine
yeah well the book yeah what people can
expect from the book is the same thing
that they saw in the Genesis lectures in
2017 except much wider and much deeper
so that's the tour too it's going be
similar to that yes yes definitely oh
okay that's very cool MH I wonder if I
can come along for some of that I don't
know you're welcome I have multiple
children now yeah that's true it's a
little tricky see if you can come for
some of bring people that he's pretty
little but they do travel they do they
do bring people along that can help you
yeah okay you know make it work make it
work but do come along maybe some maybe
like Mexico or something would be fun
yeah well and we'll probably go out on
the road again next fall so you know
even if you miss the first six months
that doesn't I don't think it it doesn't
look we'll see how these tickets sell
but
what so far it's looking good because
when we announced the new tour we put
the tickets up on sale and some of the
venues were 40% sold out within a week
without us advertising
so if the our sense is at least so far
like as long as public demand stays high
and as long as we have something new to
offer there's no real reason to stop
doing this that's very positive
experience experience and it seems to be
good for people and it's helped the ark
thing grow and we've made crazy
connections all over the world we want
to extend those into Africa and into
southeast Asia and South America and
Southeast Asia would be cool y I'm going
to join for that one yeah come to South
Korea yeah that would be really fun I'll
do that one take a whole bus load of
people yeah yeah that would be fun we'll
do a big stadium in in Soul cool MH okay
well thank you guys both for coming on
what are you excited about what are you
excited about in
2024 oh I mean I mean I'm really excited
about launching Peterson
Academy and why are you so interested in
that what has it been about you maybe
maybe part of it is you put such an
emphasis on needing a degree you're a
university Professor so I grew
up I actually was a bit confused because
I knew I wanted to have kids young and
Young to me was in my 20s and I also
thought that the best thing I could do
for my career would be to get a
PhD and I remember being like I was like
18 being like yeah I remember that
doesn't really line up like it doesn't
really line up you can't really have
kids in your 20s and get a PhD like what
how am I going to have time for both so
that was always kind of in my head maybe
that's a problem we're going to solve
with Peterson Academy maybe we can offer
people PhD Level Training if we get this
thing really humming
and
and so that young women could still have
children when that would be it solves
that would be great so it would solve
that problem but I also when I went to
University I had such an abysmal time
like everybody I learned from I mean I
had you as a dad that probably didn't
help but everybody I learned from was
like this person is not very smart
that's kind of the and I I don't think I
came from like a hotti place I was just
listening and it wasn't that interesting
and there were things that were pretty
wrong and a lot of it felt like a waste
of time and I took a loan out to go too
and I was like this is not what I
thought it was going to be and then I
had scarlet and I quit like I dropped
out anyway so I have I have like four
years and two half degrees from
switching universities and trying to
pursue different things and find
something that was interesting and I
guess i' like that
disappointment it's annoying the
university problem is annoying I think
they take advantage of a lot of young
people put them in a boatload of debt
don't teach them anything that's worth
learning and bettering themselves and
then say yeah you need this degree to
get a job it's like why why do I need
this random degree to get a job that has
nothing to do with it that's just some
weird societal thing that isn't even
relevant anymore apparently 54% of
businesses in 2024 aren't going to
require a bachelor's degree anymore it's
like it's on Newen and MIT adverti
themselves the way they did in Congress
there's no that certainly comes as no
surprise yeah I think the education
system the you know K to 12 and the
university is going to change I mean
we've gone from kids used to go to
school maybe from grade eight to maybe
grade 12 or but maybe grade 10 like
maybe a couple years of school and then
they went off and worked and now we have
kids in school from like 3 until 25 say
what what are we doing and if we could
if we could help children to find an
Avenue of interest and depth when
they're young and then launch them out
into the world then that'd be much
better that was that was a fundamental
ambition of mine back in junior high
when I was sitting in my cloud like
tearing my hair out thinking there's
this is this isw the thing is it's way
more awful now yeah cuz like my teachers
were
uninspiring but they weren't uninspiring
and ideologically addled and malevolent
right right so I thought it was bad
already now it's unconscionably bad yeah
well hopefully when we expand I mean the
other thing that excites me about
Peterson Academy I think is the social
element because it's like social media I
mean you can find people you like on
Instagram you can make connections and
things but I think having people who are
interested in learning and improving
their lives on a platform where they can
communicate with with each other because
we have the social media component could
be really beneficial for people um then
who knows how that'll grow if we can
turn on locations so people can meet
with people each other and maybe in a
year or so when we see how this is going
we can expand so that we can be teaching
younger kids yeah that' be well and
maybe we'll be able to bring people
together in conferences and so forth and
on a relatively regular basis I mean one
of the things we've envisioned as you
know is having if we have enough
students to make it worthwhile is having
local conferences where we bring you
know eight of our best professors in for
two days and bring people together and
they can meet and they can they can get
hyper educated for you know a boot camp
for for 16 hours of lectures in three
days and that could that could work very
very efficiently and it's it's also a
model that isn't necessarily targeted
only to people who are you know 18 to 22
yeah there's no reason that University
education should be targeted to people
who are 18 to 22 that just makes no
sense that that's the other thing we
should probably clarify is yes it's not
targeted towards a specific age it's if
you want learn the content it's there
you also don't have to pursue a diploma
if you don't want to you can just take
the courses and learn y uh yeah yeah and
we'll have quite a flexible
accreditation model M so yeah that's
really exciting so that's what I'm
excited about and and growing the
podcast and doing in-person podcast
obviously the baby is very exciting a
little hormonal right now but very
exciting uh and then I don't know I've
got some other things I've got the
Fuller health
uh supplements going on that seems to be
doing really well
and what else there's more well I've got
some ideas going on we have this dating
app idea right right yeah yeah we talked
about that I want to do that really
badly I wanted to do that for a while so
but that's a little bit in the future um
oh yeah and then the diet things I mean
line diet's just brand of its own now um
that seems to be helping people and I
want to keep expanding that um
because I think it's beneficial for
people and learning more about our
health right yeah and learning more
about our health so it's a lot my plate
is full that's it's definitely is
overflowing yeah well we had a great
year like 2023 was was like we planned
it quite carefully and everything we
planned worked yeah and we have a very
good team our team has been excellent
our Logistics guys our security guys our
agents yeah um smooth it's smooth yeah
our tour manager deadly people like they
don't cause trouble they're extremely
helpful they're completely on board our
secretary Jordan Spencer he's great and
and and very good all the people around
me are very good at dealing with the
public and and and that's been a a a
tricky thing to manage to find security
people who are good at Logistics and and
dealing with the public but all the
things we planned far in advance they
all laid out the art conference was
spectacularly successful and it's worked
out real well online I mean I think
Constantine kiss's talk on the arcite
alone has a million views and it's got
at least another million you know in
views in distributed platforms yeah he
nailed it and it's not the most popular
talk now oh it is no no the energy talk
by uh
Steve his name momentarily escapes me
but it's the number one talk on the on
the ark site yeah on an intelligent
energy policy not Coan right no no
wasn't Coan so so that's very exciting
the ark thing is extremely exciting and
it's a new thing yeah so yeah yeah it's
just getting going sounds good here's to
2024 then right yeah yeah well thanks
for the invitation Mick and for being
hospitable while we've been staying with
you for the last complicated three weeks
yeah well thanks for coming it's been
it's been
easy well that's good that's good yeah
that's good that's High Praise indeed
when you're staying with family yeah
yeah right
[Music]
right